possible as an example of a situation in which we can decrease the chance of making an error let's suppose that our
goal is to communicate a single bit to a hypothetical receiver and to do this we're able to transmit bits through a
so-called binary symmetric Channel which flips each bit sent through it independently with some probability
P so with probability 1 minus P the receiver will get whichever bit we intended to send but with probability P
the bit flips and the receiver gets the opposite value to whatever we sent so if we don't use the repetition
code and instead we just send whatever bit we have in mind through the channel the receiver will get the wrong bit with
probability p on the other hand if we first encode the bit we want to send using the three-bit repetition code and
then send each of the three bits of the encoding through the channel then each one of them flips with probability P so
the chances of a bit flip are now greater because there are now three bits that could possibly flip rather than one
but if at most one of the bits flips then the receiver will be able to correctly decode so we'll only get an error after
decoding if two or more of the bits flip during transmission and it's not too hard to calculate that this happens with
probability 3 * P ^2 - 2 * P Cub for values of P smaller than 1/ 12
this leads to a decrease in the probability that the receiver ends up with the wrong bit there will still be a chance of an error in this case but the
code decreases the likelihood of this and if you wanted to decrease the chance even further you could do that using a
different code including but not limited to the possibility of using a repetition code where the encoded bit is repeated
more than three times for values of P greater than 1/ 12 by by the way the code actually makes
things worse in the sense that it increases the likelihood that the receiver gets the wrong bit so we would certainly not use this code in that
situation the three-bit repetition code is a classical error correcting code but we can also consider what happens if we
try to use it to protect cubits against errors it's not a very good Quantum error correcting code as we'll see it
can correct against some errors but it makes other errors more likely it is however the first step toward the shore
code so let's see how it works for cubits first to be clear when we refer to the 3-bit repetition code being used
for cubits what we have in mind is an encoding of a cubit as is shown on the screen where Alpha 0 plus beta 1 is
encoded as Alpha 0000 0 plus beta 111 or in other words the standard basis state
is repeated three times notice in particular that this is not the same thing as repeating the quantum state three times as in a given
Quantum state s being encoded as s tensor s tensor s which is not an encoding that we would be able to
implement for an unknown Quantum State s by the no cloning theorem the encoding that we're talking
about on the other hand is very easily implemented here's a very simple Quantum circuit that does it using two initialized workspace cubits and two
controlled knot Gates now let's suppose that an error takes place after the encoding has been
performed and in particular let's suppose that a polyx operation or in other words a bit flip happens on one of
the cubits and in this figure it's the middle Cubit of course this isn't the only sort of error that could occur and you might
object to the idea that an error takes the form of this perfect unitary operation but we'll come back to this later in the lesson and for now we can
just think about it as an example here's the resulting State it's the same as the original encoding except
that the middle bit within each K has been flipped obviously we can see this from the mathematical expressions for the state
but suppose that we only had the three cubits and that we suspected that a bit flip might have occurred but we didn't know which Cubit might have been
affected one way to figure out if a bit flip occurred would be to perform a standard basis measurement and examine the outcome in this case we would see
either 0 one0 or one one with probabilities depending on Alpha and beta and in either case our conclusion
would be that the middle bit flipped but unfortunately that ruins the original Quantum State and this state
might be precious to us after all the whole point is to protect this Quantum state so this is not a good
option what we can do instead is to use the quantum circuit shown here on the screen where we feed the encoded State
into the top three cubits basically what the circuit does is to compute the parity of the standard
basis States for the top two cubits as well as for the bottom two cubits of the encoding and and this will reveal the
location of the bit flip in particular in this case we'll get the outcome one for both of these parody checks and from
that information we can conclude that it's the middle bit that's different from the other two so that's evidently the one that
flipped and crucially this does not cause the state to collapse so we now have a chance to try to correct this bit
flip so that eventually we can perhaps decode and get our original state back we'll come back to the correction
in a moment but first let's briefly consider the other possibilities for a bit flip error If instead the bit flip error
occurred on the bottom or left Mouse Cubit then we would get the outcome one Zer reading from bottom to top and again
the state wouldn't change and if the bit flip happened to the top Cubit then the output would be
01 and once again the state doesn't change and by the way if there was no
bit flip error at all then the measurement outcome is 0 0 and once again the state comes out unchanged
so let's summarize all this in the form of a table where we list each of the possible states that we obtain from at most one bit flip the measurement
outcomes which we refer to as the syndrome in the context of error correction and the correction we need to make in order to get the original
encoding back if there was no error the syndrome is z Zer and nothing needs to be done to fix the
state if the bottom or leftmost Cubit experience to bit flip the syndrome is one Zer and the appropriate correction
is to apply an xgate to the bottom or leftmost Cubit and the other two cases are
similar so if we apply the appropriate correction based on the syndrome then we'll be certain to recover the original
encoding in all four cases once again we're only considering the possibility that at most one bit
flip error occurred this wouldn't work correctly if two or three bits flipped and we also haven't considered the
possibility of other errors now let's consider a different type of error in the quantum setting bit
flip errors aren't the only errors that we need to worry about for instance we also have to worry about phase flip
errors or just phase flips for short which are described by Z Gates or equivalently poly Z